in 2017 14 year old molly russell took
her own life it was only after she died
that her parents discovered she'd spent
the last weeks of her life looking at
increasingly extreme images of self-harm
and suicide on social media we couldn't
understand why molly must have ended up
feeling
so hopeless so worthless because she'd
been such a
such a lovely lovely young person and
we're all looking forward to the
her future life
but finding that content
really explained to us how she must have
been affected by what she'd seen on
digital platforms
ian russell's campaigning was important
in shaping the new online safety bill
we now come to presentation of bill
secretary of state nadine doris after
three years in the making formally put
before parliament today online safety
bill no matter which platform you're
using tech companies will have a legal
duty to protect users from harmful
content the regulator ofcom will even
have powers to look inside the software
the algorithms that decide what content
gets pushed to which users
what we're saying is
deal with those harmful algorithms deal
with that online scam advertising don't
allow our children to have pornography
just popping up on their phones and
their screens don't use that allow those
algorithms to send our children to
suicide chat rooms protect our kids and
we'll also give journalists and
individuals robust protections for
freedom of speech
the bill has been welcomed by those
policing extremism too in the last year
we saw 20 children young people under 18
arrested in relation to terrorism
offences they're searching for answers
and finding the wrong ones in some
really dangerous online places
we approached all the big tech and
social media companies nobody wanted to
speak to us in a statement their trade
body tech uk said the bill applied to at
least 24 000 companies and they hoped
lawmakers would work with industry to
ensure it delivers its objectives but
online safety campaigners say there is a
lot of work to do
we were promised a systems and process
bill one that actually took a swipe
at the system of silicon valley and one
that would make our kids safe right
across the uk wherever they were
online and this bill does not do that
yet if the act coming out of parliament
rather than the bill going into
parliament does not protect the next
molly russell then it's not fit for
purpose and that is the marker for all
of us
the online safety bill aims to create
the world's toughest restrictions on
some tech companies that are richer and
more powerful than whole nations
lawmakers have their work cut out to
reduce online harm without limiting the
important and not so important freedoms
and benefits the online world brings us
all tom clark sky news